En realidad, el campo de Higgs está encendido ligeramente,
no es cero, sino 10 000 billones de veces más débil que su valor total,
casi como si se hubiera atascado antes de la posición de apagado.
Y este valor es crucial.
Si fuera un poquito diferente,
entonces no existiría ninguna estructura física en el universo.
Este es el primero de nuestros números peligrosos,
la fuerza del campo de Higgs.
Los teóricos han pasado décadas tratando de comprender
el porqué tiene este número afinado muy peculiar,
y han llegado a una serie de posibles explicaciones.
Tienen nombres sexis como "supersimetría"
o "grandes dimensiones extras".
No voy a entrar en los detalles de estas ideas ahora,
pero el punto clave es el siguiente:
si cualquiera explica este valor extrañamente afinado del campo de Higgs,
entonces deberíamos ver nuevas partículas creándose en el LHC
junto con el bosón de Higgs.
Hasta ahora, sin embargo, no hemos visto ninguna señal de ellas.
Pero en realidad hay un ejemplo aún peor
de este tipo de ajuste fino de un número peligroso,
y esta vez viene del otro extremo de la escala,
a partir del estudio del universo a grandes distancias.
Una de los descubrimientos más importantes de la teoría general de la relatividad
fue que el universo comenzó con una rápida expansión del espacio y el tiempo
Hace 13,8 mil millones de años, el Big Bang.
De acuerdo con las primeras versiones de la teoría del Big Bang,
el universo se ha estado expandiendo desde entonces
con la gravedad frenando poco a poco a esa expansión.
Pero en 1998, los astrónomos descubrieron
que la expansión del universo en realidad se está acelerando.
El universo es cada vez más y más grande más rápidamente
impulsado por una fuerza de repulsión misteriosa llamada energía oscura.
Cada vez que oigan la palabra "oscuro" en física,
deben ser muy cautelosos
ya que probablemente significa que no sabemos de lo que estamos hablando.
(Risas)
No sabemos qué es la energía oscura,
pero la mejor descripción es que es la energía del espacio vacío en sí,
la energía del vacío.
Si usan la buena mecánica cuántica antigua para saber
qué tan fuerte debería ser la energía oscura,
se obtiene un resultado absolutamente sorprendente.
Verán que la energía oscura
debería ser 10 a la potencia 120 veces más fuerte
que el valor que observamos con la astronomía.
Ese es un uno con 120 ceros después de él.
Este es un número tan alucinantemente enorme
que es imposible comprenderlo.
A menudo usamos la palabra "astronómico" al hablar de grandes números.
Pues bien, esa palabra no queda aquí.
Este número es más grande que cualquier número en la astronomía.
Es mil billones de billones de billones de veces más grande
que el número de átomos en el universo entero.
Es una muy mala predicción.
De hecho, se le ha llamado la peor predicción en la física,
y es algo más que una curiosidad teórica.
Si la energía oscura fuera tan fuerte,
el universo se habría desgarrado,
estrellas y galaxias no se hubieran formado y no estaríamos aquí.
Este es el segundo de esos números peligrosas,
la fuerza de la energía oscura,
y explicarla requiere un nivel aún más fantástico de afinación
que la que vimos para el campo de Higgs.
Pero a diferencia de este, no tiene ninguna explicación conocida.
La esperanza era que una combinación completa
de la teoría general de la relatividad de Einstein,
que es la teoría del universo a grandes escalas,
con la mecánica cuántica, la teoría del universo a escalas pequeñas,
podría proporcionar una solución.
El mismo Einstein pasó la mayor parte de sus últimos años
en una inútil búsqueda de una teoría unificada de la física,
y los físicos la han buscado desde entonces.
Uno de los candidatos más prometedores para una teoría unificada es
la teoría de cuerdas y la idea esencial es
que si se pudiera hacer un zoom sobre las partículas fundamentales
que componen nuestro mundo, se vería que no son partículas,
sino diminutas cuerdas vibrantes de energía,
y cada frecuencia de vibración correspondería a una partícula diferente,
un poco como notas musicales de una cuerda de guitarra.
Es una forma bastante elegante, casi poética de ver el mundo,
pero tiene un problema catastrófico.
Resulta que la teoría de cuerdas no es una teoría en absoluto,
sino toda una colección de teorías.
Se ha estimado, de hecho,
que hay 10 a la 500 versiones diferentes de la teoría de cuerdas.
Cada una pueda describir un universo diferente
con diferentes leyes de la física.
Los críticos dicen que esto hace que no sea científica.
No se puede refutar la teoría.
Sin embargo, otros lo voltean
y dicen, bueno, tal vez este aparente fracaso
es el mayor triunfo de la teoría de cuerdas.
¿Y si todos estos 10 a la 500 diferentes universos posibles
en realidad existen en alguna parte
en algún gran multiverso?
De repente podemos entender
los valores extrañamente afinados de estos dos números peligrosos.
En la mayor parte del multiverso,
la energía oscura es tan fuerte que el universo se desgarra,
o el campo de Higgs es tan débil que no hay átomos que se puedan formar.
Vivimos en uno de los lugares en el multiverso
donde los dos números son exactos.
Vivimos en un universo equilibrado.
Esta idea es muy controvertida y es fácil ver por qué.
Si seguimos esta línea de pensamiento,
nunca podremos responder a la pregunta,
"¿Porque hay algo en vez de nada?".
En la mayor parte del multiverso, no hay nada,
y vivimos en uno de los pocos lugares
donde las leyes de la física permiten que exista algo.
Lo que es peor, no podemos probar la idea del multiverso.
No podemos acceder a estos otros universos,
así que no hay forma de saber si están allí o no.
Estamos en una posición extremadamente frustrante.
Eso no significa que el multiverso no exista.
Hay otros planetas, otras estrellas, otras galaxias,
¿por qué no otros universos?
El problema es que es poco probable que alguna vez lo sepamos con seguridad.
La idea del multiverso ha estado presente por un tiempo,
pero en los últimos años, han empezado a llegar los primeros indicios sólidos
de que esta línea de razonamiento pueda cobrar fuerza.
A pesar de grandes esperanzas en la primera prueba del LHC,
lo que estábamos buscando
eran nuevas teorías de la física:
supersimetría o grandes dimensiones extras
que podrían explicar este valor extrañamente afinado del campo de Higgs.
Pero a pesar de grandes esperanzas, el LHC reveló un árido desierto subatómico
poblado solamente por un solitario bosón de Higgs.
Mi experimento publicó artículo tras artículo
donde tristemente tuvimos que concluir que no había señal de una nueva física.
Las apuestas ahora no podrían ser mayores.
Este verano, el LHC comenzó la segunda fase de operación
con una energía casi del doble de la usada en la primera prueba.
Lo que los físicos de partículas están esperando desesperadamente
son signos de nuevas partículas, micro agujeros negros,
o tal vez algo totalmente inesperado
que emerja de las violentas colisiones en el LHC.
Si es así, entonces podemos continuar este largo viaje
que empezó hace 100 años con Albert Einstein
hacia una comprensión cada vez más profunda de las leyes de la naturaleza.
Pero si, en dos o tres años,
cuando el LHC se apague de nuevo una segunda vez,
solo hemos encontrado nada más que el bosón de Higgs,
entonces podríamos estar entrando en una nueva era en la física:
una era donde hay hechos extraños del universo que no podemos explicar,
una época en la que tenemos indicios de vivir en un multiverso
que está para siempre fuera de nuestro alcance;
una era en la que nunca seremos capaces de responder a la pregunta,
"¿Porque hay algo en vez de nada?".
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Bruno Giussani: Harry, aún cuando acabas de decir
que la ciencia puede no tener algunas respuestas,
me gustaría hacerte un par de preguntas y la primera es:
la construcción de algo como el LHC es un proyecto generacional.
Acabo de mencionar, al presentarte, que vivimos en un mundo de corto plazo.
¿Cómo se pensó tan a largo plazo,
para la construcción de algo como esto?
Harry Cliff: Fui muy afortunado
al unirme al experimento con el LHC en el 2008,
justo cuando lo estábamos encendiendo,
y en mi grupo de investigación hay personas que han estado trabajando en él
durante tres décadas, toda su carrera en una sola máquina.
Creo que las primeras conversaciones sobre el LHC fueron en 1976,
y empezaron a planificar la máquina sin la tecnología
que se tenía que tener para poder construirlo.
La potencia de cálculo no existía en la década de los años 90
cuando el diseño comenzó en serio.
Uno de los grandes detectores que registran estas colisiones,
no había la tecnología
que pudiera soportar la radiación que se crearía en el LHC,
por lo que era solo un trozo de plomo en el medio
con algunos detectores alrededor,
pero después hemos desarrollado la tecnología.
Hay que confiar en que el ingenio va a resolver los problemas,
pero puede ser una década o más adelante.
BG: China, acaba de anunciar hace 2 o 3 semanas
que tiene la intención de construir
un súper colisionador de dos veces mayor tamaño que el LHC.
Me preguntaba cómo tú y tus colegas recibieron la noticia.
HC: El tamaño no lo es todo, Bruno. BG: Estoy seguro. Estoy seguro.
(Risas)
Suena chistoso que un físico de partículas diga eso.
Pero quiero decir, en serio, es una gran noticia.
Construir una máquina como el LHC
requiere que países de todo el mundo compartan sus recursos.
Ningún país puede permitirse el lujo de construir algo tan grande,
aparte de quizá China,
que puede movilizar grandes cantidades de recursos,
mano de obra y dinero para construir estas máquinas.
Es una buena noticia.
Lo que planean es construir una máquina
para estudiar el bosón de Higgs en detalle y podrían darnos pistas
sobre estas nuevas ideas, como la supersimetría,
por lo que es una gran noticia para la física, creo.
BG: Harry, gracias. HC: Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)